remember remember the fifth of November
the gunpowder treason and plot I know of
no reason why the gunpowder treason
should ever be forgot V for Vendetta was
directed by James Mateen written by the
Wachowski and came out in the year 2006
starring Natalie Portman as Evie and
Hugo Weaving as V someone labeled a
terrorist by a totalitarian government
that has taken control over England in a
very vicious way they've outlawed art a
harsh curfew is imposed upon everyone
and police officers that are in control
are rapists and criminals themselves in
this movie is based off Alan Moore's
graphic novel which if you've never read
a sprawling it is filled with amazing
characters and a ton of really great
storytelling and art now for me
personally this is one of those rare
movies that has changed for me over time
my feelings on this film have grown I
first saw it back in 2006 I was
bombarded with marketing that told me
this is what chow ski movie it's a movie
like The Matrix it's going to be all
action-packed there's going to be tons
of kung fu and fight sequences all of
the trailers mistakenly so highlighted
this very specific thing because they
wanted to make money off the very recent
Matrix Reloaded and Matrix Revolutions
and doing so made me as a teenager go to
this movie thinking I was going to get
this action-packed extravaganza and yeah
there are really great action sequences
in V for Vendetta but it was also a
movie that talks about politics and how
a government can control its people and
how a people can rise up against its
government it has a lot of ideas as well
as action set-pieces and when I first
saw it I remember being disappointed by
it and thinking man I mean I don't get
this movie didn't have any action
sequences I mean I was I was just a
teenager ready to see an action-packed
movie over the years this movie has
grown to be one of my favorite comic
book films for a number of reasons for
one when I first saw the movie I thought
it was going to be this big
action-packed film but it wasn't there's
action sequences and they're very
impressive and masterfully directed and
edited but as I got older I began to
appreciate things like the movie
storytelling its performances the
direction
not just the really cool action
sequences but the fact that as a whole
this movie has an ironclad pair of balls
so why do I say that while this movie
came out only five short years after a
devastating terrorist attack on America
9/11 and this film has a main character
that is labeled as a terrorist and
portrays him in a sympathetic light so
that we understand his motivations and
what he wants to do and why he's doing
it now granted the world surrounding V
in this movie is a futuristic depiction
of a fictionalized world in which
everything has gone to shit
and there's this one government that's
acting like it's not so in that way you
can kind of watch it and understand why
someone would rise up against it but I
also must reiterate that this is a
fictional film a lot of critics you go
back and read early reviews of this
movie when it was first released for
like this is a disturbing movie as
sympathizers with terrorism orders movie
is against America and so I was like
geez you guys are really missing the
point here it's really funny sometimes
how people can just get so worked up
with their own ideas about things and
just attribute them to films I've seen
it so often in film reviews and I'm not
going to say that I've never
accidentally done that but I try to go
into a movie and respect the film as a
film and understand that this is
something written and directed and these
are performances and this is fiction now
if it's based off a true story that's a
different thing but we're talking about
V for Vendetta
a movie that's based off of a graphic
novel and I can easily separate that
from the real world and V for Vendetta
is such a beautifully directed movie I
actually hesitate to say this was
directed a hundred percent by James
matiee because everything he's done
afterwards has never lived up to this I
kind of feel like there was a bit of a
poltergeist thing going on here do you
guys know what I'm talking about
the original poltergeist was directed by
tobe Hooper but a lot of people kind of
think that Steven Spielberg actually
kind of directed most of that movie part
of me feels like the Wachowski had a lot
to do with the actual shot structure in
this film because it very much so does
resemble the way they film the Matrix
trilogy it's a great-looking movie with
a standout performance by Hugo Weaving
SB you never see this guy's face
this severe burn victim he's had a very
tortured past and he absolutely is
certain that this world he exists in
requires change and that he can be the
one to exact that change and when he
runs across Natalie Portman's character
as Evie who's an innocent girl who gets
caught up in all of this they team up
and their relationship is one of my
favorite parts of this movie because it
never goes in the conventional route you
can tell they grow to love each other
but it's not the type of love that you
would expect to see in a film like this
there isn't a big unmasking scene where
she kisses his burned face and she
accepts how he looks or some stupid
scene like that it's all done in a very
mature way and I love that about V for
Vendetta what I also really like about
it is that this film takes all of its
principal characters and builds them in
very rich ways the best movies in
regards to character development are the
ones where you take a character in the
beginning of the movie and the end of
the movie and you look at that person
and they are completely different
Natalie Portman's evolution throughout
this film to where she is at the end is
humongous also the police detective in
this movie Finch who starts out hunting
v and Evie slowly starts to recognize
that there's other things going on other
things he needs to pay attention to with
his government with the news and you can
tell as the film goes on that even he
starts to doubt which side is right
which is hinted at in his introduction
scene where John Hurt's face on this big
monitor is talking to everyone ordering
them what to do when everyone says
England prevails the scene ends on a
close-up of Finch and he's looking down
like he's just not entirely comfortable
with even saying that you can tell
there's a seed of doubt in that
character just from his opening scene
and that's one of the best things about
V for Vendetta it's not just a movie
with great action sequences it didn't
just rely on CGI it has characters in it
that are richly developed for me one of
those films biggest pluses is that it's
wholly unpredictable when this film
starts would you possibly imagine that
Natalie Portman might at some point be
locked up in some strange illusion meant
to test her loyalty to V could you
imagine that in this movie and better
yet could you imagine it
actually working from a narrative
perspective but it does every segment in
V for Vendetta complements the other
everything builds and works to such a
cohesive and complete whole that the
entire experience of V for Vendetta is
so satisfying as I said is one of my
favorite comic book movies and I'm going
to give V for Vendetta and A+
it is for me that rare movie that truly
has grown and changed in my mind over
the years and I'm going to really
appreciate it what do you guys think of
V for Vendetta happy November the fifth
you guys are the best thank you so much
as always for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]